hi I'm Chloe a developer advocate for
Google cloud in this video we'll show
you how you can accelerate your AI
processing with Nvidia gpus on Google
Cloud even when you're subject to strict
regulatory requirements we'll start with
a quick review of the common challenges
that are faced by regulated customers
when moving workloads to the cloud and
show you how Google Cloud's assured
workloads makes this process simple
then we'll show you how it's possible to
use nvidia's technology for AI
acceleration in combination with assured
workloads and walk you through a demo of
a deployed solution so you can see it in
action ready to learn how Nvidia and
Google Cloud can help you address your
regulated AI needs let's get started
[Music]
before we dive in let's do a quick
review of assured workloads assured
workloads provides Google Cloud
customers with the ability to apply
security controls to a specific
environment in support of compliance
requirements without compromising the
quality of their Cloud experience
all organizations have to do is choose
the right regulatory framework and
Google Cloud will put the necessary
Cloud controls in place to support your
chosen compliance requirements across
the globe
for a more in-depth overview of assured
workloads be sure to take a look at our
video introduction to assured workloads
to accelerate specific workloads on your
VMS or containers such as machine
learning and data processing compute
engine and kubernetes engine provide
nvidiographics processing units that you
can add to your virtual machine
instances and kubernetes clusters
Nvidia accelerated Computing on Google
Cloud provides a suite of accelerator
options for various AI needs for
large-scale AI training Nvidia a100 gpus
are available on gcp with up to 80
gigabytes of GPU memory per chip this
includes the ability to attach 16 a100
gpus on a single VM machine shape the
largest single node GPU instance from
any major cloud provider on the market
today for AI inference Nvidia t4s on
Google Cloud offers strong price
performance to deploy AI applications
into production for low latency needs
customers are also able to deploy Nvidia
AI Solutions onto gcp from Nvidia and GC
a portal of Enterprise Services software
management tools and support for
end-to-end AI and digital twin workflows
as AI continues to change and disrupt
the way we build and interact with
technology running AI workloads in
highly regulated environments can feel
like a daunting task
many AI services such as infrastructure
platforms tools and solutions exist
today but may not be available in Cloud
infrastructure that supports highly
regulated customers and workloads this
has forced many developers into
situations with unpredictable pricing or
limited access to the latest AI
technology
now thanks to Nvidia gpus and assured
workloads you can use Google cloud and
nvidia's AI Technologies to help solve
your business problems while remaining
compliant and secure and with a public
catalog of Enterprise ready AI software
and solutions you'll have access to
Frameworks sdks and ready to go models
to help you build the custom AI
Solutions you need and with one-click
deployment through Google Cloud
Marketplace Nvidia AI Enterprise makes
it simple to deploy AI Solutions while
remaining secure and compliant giving
you access to the Nvidia AI Enterprise
software suite as well as access to
Dedicated support anytime you need it
with this greater access to technology
regions and resources for regulated
workloads using assured workloads in
combination with Nvidia gpus can help
tackle use cases like anomaly detection
and Manufacturing predictive maintenance
as well as image classification tasks
allowing you to quickly and easily build
and run Solutions while remaining secure
compliant and with reduced cost and risk
thanks for tuning in for more
information check out our documentation
or take a look at the links provided in
the description below for more info on
how you can use assured workloads in
Nvidia for your regulated AI Cloud needs
[Music]
please